then what caught immobilo were you able
to drive to it was in fact in the
speciality today it was I am proud to
say the very first media drive in us
Shores I'm the first person to drive as
a journalist of the car on a track or
any bit of asphalt in the US hey Gav
he's a good day there are no keys to
this so this is just a push-button
affair no no there is a key you turn the
Kenya then the red button which is you
know you know somebody's driven a
Ferrari before if they turn the key and
expect it to start because you have to
turn the key and then hit the red button
and then here that beautiful vibrant
sound that comes only from a Ferrari
that seems almost worth 288 doesn't it
yeah what else in the car makes you feel
that it might be worth that or even a
bit more tell us how this felt this is
special now I've been looking forward
I've when I drove the 458 I thought how
could you get faster better performing
car every time that Ferrari does one is
the iterations of their mid-engine
really hardcore sports cards which are
different from the mid-engine rear-wheel
drive I gotta make these a clear they do
have a four-wheel trip indeed and they
have a four-wheel drive and they have
you know their front engine or more sort
of generally cars that you might take a
long trip these are cars you take on the
racetrack and go pummel around now the
speciality is a version that is stripped
down it's much more hardcore and you're
supposed to do exactly what I did today
which was I took it from the city I
drove an hour and 40 minutes to
Monticello racetrack which is a private
racetrack in the catskills drove it horn
for about three hours had a little lunch
how to coffee got back in the car just
in time to ride here it's a car you can
track during the you know you can track
during the day and get back home in
which is which is kind of its its
purpose what color was the car chase
let's start with the most basic now
indeed it was Ferrari red Ferrari red
robbery the interiors got the suede
right the doctors got awesome powers
wait it's very nice but I was told that
the reason they have that in Marco you
can come in on this is because it's much
less weight yes then leather or
obviously suede you don't want to get it
dirty don't want that new sorry but that
it really helps to reduce about half the
weight of a traditional leather tria we
are when we talk about 45 especially
racing car we are obsessed in reducing
as much as we can the weight of the car
so every material
really give me some lotto formats yes we
took no floor mats you don't get format
floor mats but well but it's just
beautiful sort of expose is it is it
aluminum yes hello me in so your feet on
this beautiful exposed aluminum it feels
purposeful and and the door handles are
this beautiful crafted carbon fiber and
it's actually the seats are very
comfortable they don't recline but I'm
surprised they're well bolstered but
they're really comfortable um it is it
is important that to feel like a gloves
I mean you need to feel integrated with
the car is your part of the growth rate
is a fundamental part of the driving us
p well is it true for example that in
many cases of Ferrari you know you're
going to come with a 4-point harness
because you want to feel really locked
into the automobile and if you have
something in the passenger seat next you
forget it you're not going to be able to
reach it no they won't sell it to you
like that you have to do that yourself
in the US the oils are not allowed to
sell for 4-point harness automobiles
unless you buy a challenge and just
write down the fourth a racecar let's
talk a little bit about using the
software algorithmic package because we
were just talking about with Marco this
SSC the side slip control did you feel
it work because it's supposed to send
these all these you know split second
not even split second you know
algorithmic messages to the rear to the
differential in order to compensate for
understeer or oversteer Hafer is not to
inverness they're not the only company
doing these similar things which is
torque vectoring they're using the brake
system or vectoring yeah it's n czyli
they're using all the systems to make
you do what you actually want to do what
you're hoping you're due in old cars you
know you would understand you're pushing
out to the towards the track or you know
your car gets away from you this car
today I drove on the track really quite
hard it's still fairly cold out um on a
perfect day would be 75 degrees today
was you know 50 um so what does that
mean you don't get it up to 9000 rpm oh
I had definitely I had it lit up pretty
good I think even on the short streets
we had about up 235 miles an hour better
though is the way it maneuvers I was
going around curves this is a track I
spent a lot of time on and a lot of
different cars
I was able to do some line today so I'm
taking a certain paths on this track
that I would not be able to do with most
cars and that's because of these listen
all the 458 speciale a United States
come with the telemetry package so
everything is going to tell us is gonna
be download as a laboratory by the
telemetry package that allows you to
what put an USB or an iPad app that you
can then yes you are in volume going
around all the information button so you
know what I got up to today basically
don't if I got it Amy also we can review
everything that he did do you do if a
witness permission we will do but
basically this is important because you
want really the driver engage with the
car understand these performers
improving his performer understanding
the points were in the truck he can
improve so is a fundamental things to
understand of a ferrari world and how
you get ending your Ferrari so that's
one of them go ahead was the interesting
thing was driving on the freeway drive
normal roads even around town here it
didn't beat me up and usually when you
get more of a focused hardcore race car
type consumer car they beat you up they
built wreck this car actually it's still
pretty comfortable you know what else
happens sometimes in a regular consumer
automobile as they recall them have you
heard about all of the recalls from
Toyota and General Motors and so on yes
roopesh Marco I'm sure you've heard
about this and you don't wish this on
anybody in the industry but I mean are
they doing the right thing by the
consumer me has anything ever happened
to let's say a Ferrari I mean you must
have the names of everybody that buys
them so you get to connect with these
individuals and I'm not in the position
to judge if the other are doing well or
learn it well what a job what I'm saying
is that there is no a perfect product in
any industry so we need to get used in
order to make sure that if there is an
issue you jump on the issue you fix it
and probably you communicate to your
customer to your network a you fixed
issue but you need to be straightforward
and you need to have a incredible time
or reaction to this in today's society
everything you gotta wear immediately so
it is important that really you
understand the issues and you fix it
right away a you communicate properly
that's our philosophy Safety's the
important topic for us all the
investment in Formula One are even in
that direction you see the impressive
improvement in Formula One in the last
20 years in term is safety you see all
these technological transferring our
cast and this is a priority for us we're
going to find out more about the
competition formula when I want to ask
you about what Mercedes has been doing
in Formula One but Jason I just want to
point to you this idea of automobiles
that then take very sophisticated
high-end technology such as what's in
this and it trickles down after many
years into the cars that everybody
drives on a day-to-day basis more more
quickly as a matter of fact you look at
your average kiya aur Hyundai today
they're using all this technology would
have found in an s-class Mercedes four
years ago so the fact is in a lot of it
is quite safety-minded of applying spot
protection is self driving in sort of
keeping oh I don't think you want to do
self driving with that's before 58 touch
other you don't know it is trickle down